Jake: 然后一个秒表
Jake: Okay, then we need a stopwatch.
Shure:  时间戳呗
Shure: Mark a timestamp, right?
Jake: 戳一下
Jake: Mark it.
Jake: 都戳一下
Jake: Everyone, mark it.
Jake: 每人戳一下
Jake: Each person, mark it.
Jake: 传过去戳一下哎
Jake: Pass it along and mark it.
Jake: 你能看到对吗
Jake: You can see it, right?
Jake: 好戳完了
Jake: Alright, all marked.
Jake: 行
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 开机开
Jake: Turn it on.
Jake: 那
Jake: So,
Jake:就是今天我们就讨论讨论
Jake: Today we're just going to discuss,
Jake: 早上讨论
Jake: Discuss in the morning.
Jake: 讨论我们最后一天干点啥呗
Jake: Discuss what to do on our last day.
Jake: 然后可能
Jake: And maybe,
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm,
Jake: 就是这边还有4个
Jake: So we have 4 of these,
Jake: 这个USB就可能这
Jake: These USBs, so maybe this,
Jake: 这叫什么
Jake: What's it called?
Jake: 这个硬盘
Jake: This hard drive.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 早上我觉得大家主要是讨论
Jake: I think in the morning we should mainly discuss,
Jake: 然后讨论的时候闲着没事
Jake: And if we have nothing to do while discussing,
Jake: 如果大家陷入了沉思
Jake: If everyone falls into deep thought,
Jake: 陷入了尴尬
Jake: Or it gets awkward,
Jake: 可以把这个给装一装
Jake: We can install this.
Jake: 对只是一个back up
Jake: Yeah, just as a backup.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 所以
Jake: So,
Jake: 现在就尴尬了啊
Jake: Now it's awkward, huh?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure: 先看拆了看看是什么
Shure: Let's first open it and see what it is.
Jake: 行那也行那也行
Jake: Okay, that works too.
Shure:  哇哦
Shure: Wow.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey.
Lucia: 只有4个吗
Lucia: Only 4 of them?
Jake: 对只有4个
Jake: Yeah, just 4.
Katrina:  没事没事
Katrina: No problem, no problem.
Lucia: 我拆过这个
Lucia: I've opened this before.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake: 因为你是menter
Jake: Because you're a mentor.
Lucia: 啊对
Lucy: Ah, right.
Jake: tutor
Jake: Tutor.
Lucia: 哈哈我已经装过这个东西了
Lucia: Haha, I’ve already installed this thing.
Shure:  需要充电宝在这里拿
Shure: If you need a power bank, you can get one here.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Jake: 我先把这些端走
Jake: I'll take these away first.
Katrina: 哇还有螺丝呀
Katrina: Wow, there are even screws.
Jake: 大家拆出来了可以摆成什么样呢
Jake: So, what can you guys assemble it into?
Jake: 摆成
Jake: Assemble it into...
Jake: 这个盒子要留着
Jake: We need to keep this box.
Jake: 嗯里边这个东西可以丢掉
Jake: Hmm, you can throw away what's inside.
Jake: 这东西都丢掉吧
Jake: Just throw all this away.
Jake: 这眼镜布留着
Jake: Keep this glasses cloth.
Jake: 好那就先摆成这样
Jake: Alright, let's set it up like this for now.
Jake: 这个是等大家陷入沉思的时候再用
Jake: We'll use this when everyone is deep in thought.
Jake: 但是这个我可以跟大家先讲一下
Jake: But I can explain this to you guys first.
Jake: 这个东西是什么呢
Jake: So what is this thing?
Jake: 就大家可以看这个地方
Jake: You guys can look at this part.
Jake: 你们也看不见这个地方
Jake: Actually, you can't see this part.
Jake: 或者你们过来吧
Jake: Or you can come over.
Jake: 走动走动
Jake: Move around a bit.
Jake: 就是看我的工作间
Jake: Just take a look at my workspace.
Shure:  我们这算私闯闺房吗
Shure: Are we trespassing?
Jake: 那请请请请
Jake: No, no, please come in.
Jake: 工作间
Jake: This is my workspace.
Jake: 然后这地方是一共有6台电脑对吧
Jake: And this place has a total of 6 computers, right?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake: 然后这7台
Jake: And then 7.
Jake: 8台
Jake: 8.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 9台 10台
Jake: 9, 10.
Jake: 但是就是这边6台电脑
Jake: But there are 6 computers here.
Jake: 每一个电脑
Jake: Each computer...
Jake: 都对应着你们的一个一台眼镜
Jake: Corresponds to one of your glasses.
Jake: 然后这个每一台电脑
Jake: And every computer...
Jake: 你们每次录完结束
Jake: After you finish recording each time...
Jake: 每隔三个小时
Jake: Every three hours...
Jake: 然后会嗯就是在这儿导到这个硬盘里边
Jake: You need to transfer it to this hard drive.
Jake: 然后这个硬盘
Jake: And this hard drive
Jake: 就是你们一会要装的硬盘
Jake: This is the hard drive you guys will install later.
Shure: 嗷
Shure: Oh.
Jake: 就是比方说这个这个L1这个L1这个L2
Jake: For example, this L1, this L1, this L2.
Jake: 然后这个名字的名字都写在这了
Jake: And the names are all written here.
Jake: 哈哈哈你们的数据都在这个里边
Jake: Haha, all your data is in here.
Shure:  这我们的第二生命
Shure: This is our second life.
Lucia: 呵呵呵呵呵
Lucia: Hehehe.
Jake: 对你们的第二生命都在这个里边啊
Jake: Yes, your second life is all in here.
Jake: 比方说我这个L1
Jake: For example, my L1.
Jake: 对吧然后你们结束之后
Jake: Right, after you finish
Jake: 就是会把这个眼镜插到这个上面
Jake: 然后同时
Jake: And at the same time
Jake: 现在一直接着这个第一个硬盘
Jake: now, this first hard drive is continuously connected.
Jake: 对然后这个硬盘它有两根线
Jake: Yes, and this hard drive has two cables.
Jake: 一个是一个是接电脑的
Jake: One is connected to the computer.
Jake: 一个是接电源的
Jake: One is connected to the power.
Jake: 然后这个电源
Jake: And this power
Jake: 是为了让这个硬盘假装自己在电脑上
Jake: is to make the hard drive pretend it is in the computer.
Jake:呵呵 所以这个盒的意思就是说
Jake: Haha, so the purpose of this box is
Jake: 他给模拟一个电脑的环境
Jake: to simulate a computer environment.
Shure: 诱骗器
Shure: A decoy.
Jake:对对 让硬盘能知道自己要工作了
Jake: Yes, yes, to make the hard drive know it needs to work.
Jake: 对啊然后这个线啊
Jake: Yes, and this cable,
Jake: 这个线我们我们布线还挺有意思的
Jake: this cable, our wiring is quite interesting.
Jake: 就长成这个样子
Jake: It looks like this.
Jake: 呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 是一个悬着的啊
Shure: It's hanging, right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 那如果突然停电了会怎么样
Shure: What happens if there's a sudden power outage?
Jake: 那不好讲
Jake: That's hard to say.
Jake: 就是电脑突然停电
Jake: If the computer suddenly loses power,
Jake: 就是会很尴尬
Jake: it would be very awkward.
Shure:  那没有什么
Shure: Then there's nothing like
Shure:  就是USB之类的
Shure: a USB or something,
Shure:  嗯就是那种备用电源
Shure: like a backup power supply.
Jake: 哦哦没有
Jake: Oh, no.
Jake: 还没那么有钱
Jake: We are not that rich yet.
Jake: 我们只能相信这个别墅
Jake: We can only trust this villa
Jake: 或者相信北京电力吧
Jake: or trust Beijing Power.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Shure:  感谢
Shure: Thanks.
Jake: 好你们都开始装了
Jake: Okay, you all started assembling.
Shure:  我们
Shure: We...
Shure:  我们可以
Shure: We can...
Jake:可以边聊边装嘛
Jake: You can chat while assembling.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Jake: 嗯或者说你们先带你们带了什么嘛
Jake: Hmm, or you can first show what you brought.
Jake: 你们带了什么
Jake: What did you bring?
Jake: 哎这个这个眼镜你得带好
Jake: Hey, these glasses, you need to wear them properly.
Jake: 这眼镜
Jake: These glasses...
Jake: 嗯也不能遮住
Jake: Hmm, they shouldn't cover...
Jake: 应该都不没遮住吧
Jake: They shouldn't cover anything, right?
Jake: 现在没遮住
Jake: Now they're not covering.
Lucia:  但这里有一个孔
Lucia: But there's a hole here.
Lucia: 然后这个地方是要坐在这的
Lucia: And this part needs to sit here.
Lucia: 所以你要就是最好这样对齐
Lucia: So you should align it like this.
Lucia: 然后慢慢往里推
Lucia: And then slowly push it in.
Lucia: 看怎么样能推进去
Lucia: See how you can push it in.
Lucia: 好像要轻一点
Lucia: Seems like you need to be gentle.
Lucia: 那天那同学跟我说这个挺脆弱的
Lucia: That day, a classmate told me this is quite fragile.
Jake: 嗯对就是
Jake: Hmm, yes, exactly.
Shure:  没事搞定
Shure: No worries, it's done.
Lucia: 就是这不是有一个口吗
Lucia: There's a notch here, right?
Lucia: 跟这个是对着的
Lucia: It matches with this part.
Lucia: 你就像他们这样对着
Lucia: So you align it like this.
Lucia: 然后慢慢地推
Lucia: And then slowly push it.
Lucia: 看这样手里能有推进去
Lucia: See if it can be pushed in by hand.
Lucia: 要稍微使点力气
Lucia: Apply a bit of force.
Lucia: 他这还是有一点紧的
Lucia: It's still a bit tight.
Lucia: 但是需要别太使劲
Lucia: But don't use too much force.
Lucia: 别掰坏了
Lucia: Don't break it.
Shure:  没有吧
Shure: No, right?
Lucia: 好像很脆弱的样子
Lucia: It seems very fragile.
Lucia: 不过我其实也不是很懂这个
Lucia: But honestly, I don't really understand this.
Jake: 有有有很多螺丝
Jake: There are lots of screws.
Lucia: 要拧螺丝
Lucia: Need to screw them in.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Shure: 那螺丝呢
Shure: Where are the screws?
Lucia: 在那里面
Lucia: Inside there.
Shure:  哦懂了
Shure: Oh, got it.
Shure:  easy
Shure: Easy.
Katrina:  然后就把它装进去了
Katrina: And then we just put it in.
Lucia: 嗯对然后要装到这个盒子里
Lucia: Yeah, right, and then it goes into this box.
Lucia: 就是你最好是把这个地方取下来
Lucia: You should probably remove this part.
Lucia: 然后这个片就可以不要了
Lucia: And you don't need this piece.
Lucia: 因为这里一会要也要用来拧螺丝
Lucia: Because we're going to use this part to screw in the screws later.
Alice: 是不是只要拧4个螺丝
Alice: Do we just need to screw in 4 screws?
Lucia: 呃8个
Lucia: Uh, 8 screws.
Alice:8个吗？
Alice: 8 screws?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Lucia: 就是你你把那个条抽出来
Lucia: So you pull that strip out.
Lucia: 对然后就你看到那个孔了没
Lucia: Yeah, and then you see that hole?
Lucia: 长条形那个
Lucia: The long one.
Lucia: 他那里面也有一个螺丝孔
Lucia: There's a screw hole inside there too.
Lucia: 你要把那个也上上
Lucia: You need to screw that in too.
Lucia: 就是那个是大螺丝的螺丝孔
Lucia: That's the screw hole for the large screws.
Katrina:  啊哪个
Katrina: Which one?
Lucia: 呃这一个
Lucia: Uh, this one.
Alice:我已经上上完一个螺丝
Alice: I've already screwed one in.
Lucia: 就是这个这个东西
Lucia: It's this thing.
Lucia: 嗯我怎么样给你指的比较清楚
Lucia: Hmm, how can I point it out more clearly...
Lucia: 哎你上的这是对的
Lucia: Hey, the one you did is right.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Lucia: 对然后这边每个都有
Lucia: Yeah, and there are screws on each side.
Lucia: 然后这个也是所以一共是8个
Lucia: And this one too, so there are 8 in total.
Lucia: 对的
Lucia: That's right.
Alice:嗷懂了
Alice: Oh, I see.
Alice: 看见了
Alice: I see it.
Katrina: 这是大螺丝
Katrina: This is the large screw.
Katrina:  是上在这是吗
Katrina: Look, it's here.
Lucia: 对对
Alice: 哦里边是把它插进去就行了吧
Alice: Oh, the inside part just needs to be inserted, right?
Alice: 就那个
Alice: Just that part.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Alice: 呃那个对
Alice: Uh, that one, right.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia: 里面应该插进去
Lucia: It should be inserted inside.
Lucia: 集成电路还是什么
Lucy: Integrated circuit or something?
Jake: 上一回我们一直在抱怨磁吸的问题
Jake: Last time, we kept complaining about the magnetic issue.
Jake: 但是好像今天大家都没有什么
Jake: But it seems like today, no one has any problems.
Lucia: 对今天大家好像接受良好
Lucia: Yeah, today everyone seems to be fine with it.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Alice:什么磁吸
Alice: What magnetic issue?
Shure:  毕毕竟附赠的这个不可能给你
Shure: Well, after all, the free one can't give you that.
Lucia: 就是就是
Lucia: Exactly, exactly.
Lucia: 这个螺丝刀它没有磁吸
Lucia: This screwdriver doesn't have a magnetic tip.
Lucia: 对所以就是在
Lucia: 放螺丝的时候就很慢
Lucia: 对是这里是放大的
Lucia: Yeah, this one's for the bigger ones.
Katrina:  嗯大的能卡进去
Katrina: Hmm, the bigger ones can fit in.
Lucia: 呃他就是这样子
Lucia: Uh, it's just like this.
Lucia: 他没有办法就穿过这个孔
Lucia: It can't go through the hole.
Lucia: 你就是要把
Lucia: You just need to...
Jake:你的头发总喜欢挡着镜头
Jake: Your hair keeps blocking the camera.
Jake: 要不想想办法
Jake: Can you do something about it?
Jake: 对或者塞到里边去
Jake: Yeah, or maybe tuck it inside.
Lucia: 大家是只要把它固定住就好
Lucia: Everyone just needs to secure it in place.
Lucia: 是是这样吗
Lucia: Is that right?
Jake: 嗯这个好
Jake: Hmm, this is good.
Shure:  我们
Shure: We...
Shure:  是不是可以有一点BGM
Shure: Should we have some background music?
Jake:让音乐放一点
Alice:支持
Alice: I support that.
Shure:  大家平时爱听什么类型的音乐
Shure: What kind of music does everyone usually listen to?
Katrina:  我我听陶喆
Katrina: I, I listen to David Tao.
Jake: 陶喆类型的音乐
Jake: David Tao type of music.
Katrina:  嗯RMB
Katrina: Hmm, R&B
Lucia: 我是混欧美圈的
Lucia: I mix in the Western circles.
Lucia: 所以就乱听
Lucia: So, I listen to all sorts of stuff.
Alice: 给大家一个比较干劲的
Alice: Let's play something energetic for everyone.
Katrina:  他那个东北雨姐的BGM
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:来自东北
Katrina:  干活的时候必须贼有劲
Katrina: When working, it has to be very energizing.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 来跳吧要不然
Jake: Let's dance, otherwise...
Shure:  我想扛起来了
Shure: I feel like lifting it up.
Katrina: 扛起来
Katrina：Lifting it up.
Shure:  呵呵呵这个半嵌入就行是吧
Shure: Haha, just half embed it, right?
Shure:  这样
Shure: Like this.
Jake: 对对
Alice: OK
Alice: OK.
Shure: 大东北 我的家乡
Shure: Big Northeast, my hometown.
Jake: 你东北哪的呀
Jake: Which part of the Northeast are you from?
Shure: 稻花香
Shure: Daohuaxiang.
Jake: 东北稻花的
Jake: Daohuaxiang in the Northeast?
Shure:  不是不是
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  那个长春的
Shure: It's Changchun.
Jake: 长春的
Jake: Changchun.
Shure: 吉林省长春市
Shure: Changchun, Jilin Province.
Shure:  大家知道这个城市吗
Shure: Does everyone know this city?
Katrina: 知道呀
Katrina: Yeah, we know.
Shure:  大家知道吉林省还有个吉林市吗
Shure: Do you know there's also a city called Jilin in Jilin Province?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake:对这也知道
Jake: Yeah, we know that too.
Jake: 怎么你在吉林市
Jake: So, you're in Jilin City?
Shure:  没有我在长春
Shure: No, I'm in Changchun.
Jake: 你们隔壁
Jake: Next door.
Shure:  好像是
Shure:  大东北
Shure: Big Northeast.
Shure:  AI人类为什么喜欢听这样的音乐
Shure: Why do AI humans like listening to this kind of music?
Lucia: 人类迷惑行为
Lucia: Human puzzling behavior.
Jake: 然后这边有一个螺丝
Jake: And there's a screw here.
Jake: 你看两边
Jake: Look at both sides.
Lucia: 外面这好像不装回去也
Lucia: It seems like we don't need to put this one back.
Lucia: 也可以就这个条
Lucia: We can just leave this strip.
Lucia: 我们那天反正好像都扔了我记得
Lucia: I remember we threw them all away the other day anyway.
Lucia: 我记得
Lucy: I remember.
Lucia: 这条可以扔
Jake: 任意摆
Jake: 我昨天成功的放了进去
Jake: I successfully put it in yesterday.
Lucia: 哦哦哦原来如此
Lucia: Oh, I see.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 那那那咱那天的嘞
Lucia: What about the one from that day?
Jake: 没关系
Jake: It's fine.
Jake: 它就是美观
Jake: It's just for aesthetics.
Jake: 它就是看的没有螺丝
Jake: So it looks like there are no screws.
Jake: 然后把它这样
Jake: Then put it like this.
Shure: 可以进厂了
Shure: We can go into the factory now.
Alice: 可以我已经进过厂了
Alice: Sure, I’ve been in a factory before.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake: 啊你你进过厂玩过
Jake: Oh, you've been in a factory before?
Alice: 我觉得我们大学那些接线的
Alice: I think the wiring we did in college...
Alice: 焊板子的跟进厂没啥区别
Alice: ...and soldering boards wasn't much different from factory work.
Jake: 物联网吗
Jake: Internet of Things?
Jake: 还是什么
Jake: Or what?
Katrina:  嗯电工
Alice: 对电工
Alice: Yes, electrician.
Lucia: 焊板子的
Lucia: 看吧对电工实习会做一些神奇的东西 我们学校也是
Lucia: See, during our electrician internships, we also made some amazing things. Same at our school.
Jake: 最后最后放成这个样子
Jake: In the end, it turns out like this.
Jake: 好吧然后就就可以出叫出厂了对
Jake: Well, then it can be shipped out, right?
Jake: 出流水线
Jake: Off the assembly line.
Jake: 下一个流水线
Jake: Next assembly line.
Lucia: 下一个流水线是让你接到电脑上的
Lucia: The next assembly line connects to the computer.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Shure:  下一个需要高级技工
Shure: The next one requires a skilled technician.
Lucia: 哈哈哈高级技工
Lucia: Hahaha, skilled technician.
Katrina: 3,000
Alice: 查查的
Alice: Check it out.
Jake: 3,000的技工到5,000的技工
Jake: A technician from 3,000 to 5,000.
Shure:  你说的这是技工吗
Shure: Are you talking about technicians?
Alice: 什么是技工？鸡公煲？
Lucia: 技术工人
Lucia: Skilled worker.
Shure:  哎为什么我
Shure: Hey, why do I...
Alice: 因为你按反了啊
Alice: Because you pressed it the wrong way.
Jake: 这个是有俩螺丝啊
Jake: There are two screws here.
Shure:  嗷嗷哎哎
Shure:  完了太丢人了
Shure: Oh no, this is so embarrassing.
Jake: 2,000的
Jake: 2,000.
Shure: 倒数第一了
Shure: Last place.
Jake:2,000了
Jake: 2,000.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 不行我必须要争一下
Shure: No way, I have to compete.
Shure:  我不能倒数第一
Shure: I can't be last place.
Jake: 哈哈好
Jake: Haha, okay.
Jake: 硬盘硬盘锦标赛
Jake: Hard drive championship.
Katrina: 就不用干什么了吗
Katrina：Do we not need to do anything anymore?
Lucia: 拧完应该就就好了
Shure:  他风轻云淡的说一句拧完了
Shure:  然后
Jake:哈哈哈
Shure:  他挑衅我
Shure:  我靠
Jake:到底还有机会吗
Katrina:  是这样吗
Lucia: 应该是吧
Jake: 对对对放到这个盒子里面
Shure:  你看你没有装上那一关
Jake: 这就是最后一步
Jake: 给你一点机会但是你还是没有抓住
Lucia: 你可以把条放在里面
Lucia: 如果需要装的话
Lucia: 然后尽量自己装就好了
Jake: 没需要装完全没必要放里面就好
Shure:  OK
Shure:  他已经可以出场了出场
Jake: 好谢谢大家
Jake: 完成了一个奇怪的第一次任务
Jake: Finished a weird first task.
Jake: 然后这个EGO life最后一天
Jake: And then on the last day of this EGO life.
Jake: 大家会邀请什么人呢
Jake: Who will everyone invite?
Shure:  啊最后一天
Shure: Ah, the last day.
Jake: 最后一天
Jake: The last day.
Shure: 是周日是吗
Shure: It's Sunday, right?
Jake: 是周周日周日下午吧
Jake: It's on Sunday afternoon, right?
Shure:  啊咱俩会邀请什么人
Shure: Ah, who will the two of us invite?
Jake: 会邀请几个人
Jake: We'll invite a few people.
Jake: 呀
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 应该
Lucia: Probably.
Shure: 黑板写一写吧
Shure: Let's write it on the blackboard.
Jake: 对黑板可以写一写
Jake: Yeah, we can write it on the blackboard.
Shure:  来我来我字非常好看
Shure: Here, let me do it, my handwriting is great.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 我们还有一个架子
Jake: We also have a shelf.
Jake: 要不我们也拼一下好
Jake: How about we assemble it too?
Shure:  什么架子
Shure: What shelf?
Shure:  就是不是
Shure: I mean, isn't it...
Jake: 你如果觉得这个这么写很难写的话
Jake: If you think it's hard to write it this way...
Jake: 它其实有一个
Jake: Actually, it has one.
Shure:  没有笔
Shure: No pen.
Jake: 就这个东西就是你可以假装再装吧
Jake: With this thing, you can just pretend to install it again.
Shure:  行问题不大是吧
Shure: Okay, not a big deal, right?
Shure:  问题不大
Shure: Not a big deal.
Jake:问题不大
Jake: Not a big deal.
Shure:  不影响我这个书法的发挥
Shure: It won't affect my calligraphy performance.
Jake: 笔呢
Jake: Where's the pen?
Shure: 笔呢
Shure: Where's the pen?
Shure: 好问题
Shure: Good question.
Jake:好问题
Jake: Good question.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure:  问问他问问AI
Shure: Ask him, ask AI.
Shure:  笔呢
Shure: Where's the pen?
Jake:笔呢
Jake: Where's the pen?
Lucia: 寻找我的iPhone吗
Lucia: Looking for my iPhone?
Jake: 哈哈哈对笔呢
Jake: Hahaha, yeah, where's the pen?
Lucia: 寻找我的
Lucia: Looking for my...
Lucia: 寻找我的pencil
Lucia: Looking for my pencil.
Jake: 笔应该在上面
Jake: The pen should be up there.
Jake: 等一下啊
Jake: Wait a moment.
Shure:  我们都是iPhone
Shure: We all have iPhones.
Lucia: 好像应该是
Lucia: It seems so.
Alice: 我是ePhone
Alice: I have an ePhone.
Shure:  咦什么烂梗啊哈哈哈
Shure: Eh, what kind of lame joke is that, hahaha.
Lucia: 啊这是个梗吗
Lucia: Ah, is that a joke?
Lucia: 我为什么没有GEt到
Katrina:  他是e人
Katrina: He's an e-person.
Lucia: 哦哦OK
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Lucia: 哎所以我们的e人到底是哪两位啊
Lucia: So, who are our e-people?
Jake: 一
Jake: One.
Shure: 我我也是一
Shure: Me, I'm also an e.
Lucia: 哎你是一吗
Lucia: Oh, you're an e?
Shure:  啊我我是E不是1啊OK
Shure: Ah, I'm an E, not a 1, okay.
哈哈哈
Hahaha
Jake:有啥差别啊
Jake: What's the difference?
Jake: 啊你是1哦
Jake: Ah, you're a 1.
Lucia: 所以哎那我们是6啊
Lucia: So, we're six?
Katrina:  算算一两
Katrina: Count, one, two.
Lucia: 哎那咱俩是然后呢
Lucia: So, the two of us, and then?
Lucia: 啊OK昨天我没有
Lucia: Ah okay, yesterday I didn't
Lucia: 昨天我没有猜出来
Lucia: Yesterday I didn't guess it
Lucia: 虽然我猜到他可能是E人
Lucia: Although I guessed he might be an E person
Shure: EGO life
Shure:  最后一天的名单行啊
Shure: The final day's list, okay
Shure:  你
Shure: You
Shure:  喵
Shure: Meow
Jake:哈哈是这么写的
Jake: Haha, that's how you write it
Jake: 笔画11是这么写的
Jake: Stroke 11, that's how you write it
Shure:  是这么写的
Shure: That's how you write it
Shure:  夹怎么写
Shure: How do you write "夹"
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 啊太久没写
Shure: Ah, it's been too long since I wrote it
Tasha: 宝盖头
Tasha: Roof radical
Katrina: 宝盖头
Katrina: Roof radical
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Shure:  OK第一位
Shure: Okay, first one
Jake: 小硕你邀请几个人啊
Jake: Shure, how many people are you inviting?
Shure:  我浅浅邀一个吧
Shure: I'll just invite one casually
Jake: 浅浅浅先邀一个啊
Jake: 鲁亚呢
Jake: What about Luya?
Lucia: 我不太确定因为咱们这太远了
Lucia: I'm not sure because it's too far for us
Lucia: 我不知道我小伙伴过不过得来
Lucia: I don't know if my friends can make it
Jake: 好那你的工作室
Jake: Okay, then your studio
Tasha: 我浅浅邀请一个吧
Tasha: I'll casually invite one
Jake: 好浅浅邀请一个
Jake: Okay, casually invite one
Shure:  叫什么名字
Shure: What's the name?
Jake: 用不着用不着
Jake: No need, no need
Jake: 这就用不
Jake: No need to
Jake: 着了就是大概画个正字得了
Jake: Just mark it with a tally mark
Shure:  啊画正字好
Shure: Ah, tally mark is good
Jake: 或者你用那个小球
Jake: Or use that small ball
Jake: 我估计也够
Jake: I think that's enough
Katrina:  画小人吧
Katrina: Draw little figures
Katrina:  男生就是这样
Katrina: Boys are like this
Katrina:  女生夹两边
Katrina: Girls have two on the sides
Shure:  你邀请
Shure: You invite
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: 这是你邀请的女生吗
Tasha: Is this the girl you invited?
Tasha: 啊你啊
Tasha: Ah, you?
Tasha: 那我也邀请一位女生
Tasha: Then I'll invite a girl.
Lucia: 你这个你这个辫
Lucia: Your, your braid...
Lucia: 他这个接口没有在头上
Lucia: The connection isn't at the top.
Katrina:  这个假发我的天呐
Katrina: This wig, oh my God.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure: 我们冲天一下哎
Shure: Let's spike it up.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 我应该邀请一个男生
Katrina: I should've invited a guy.
Shure:  男生
Shure: A guy?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Alice: 我爱心童的
Alice: I'm full of love.
Katrina: 哈哈三条腿
Katrina: Haha, three legs.
Jake: 哈哈哈这合适吗这样
Jake: Hahaha, is this suitable like this?
Shure:  对不起不小心画出头
Shure: Sorry, I accidentally drew the head.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Lucia: 我其实可以问一个女生
Lucia: Actually, I could ask a girl.
Lucia: 但我不确定她能不能过得来
Lucia: But I'm not sure she can make it.
Lucia: 因为她那边挺远的
Lucia: Because it's quite far for her.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈存疑是吧存疑
Lucia: Hahaha, doubtful, right? Doubtful.
Jake: 还有你可以在每个人下面写一个名字
Jake: Also, you can write a name under each person.
Jake: 写一个他的host
Jake: Write down their host.
Shure:  host是吗
Shure: The host, right?
Jake: 嗯就是你的代号嘛
Jake: Yeah, like your code name.
Shure:  嗯认领一下
Shure: Yeah, claim it.
Jake: 不不不
Jake: No, no, no.
Jake: 你就在这个小人的下面写一个
Jake: Just write it under the little person.
Jake: 或者在上面或者脸上写一个之类的
Jake: Or above, or on the face or something.
Shure:  这是谁的来着那
Shure: Whose is this again?
Alice: 呃他上他上
Alice: Umm, it's his, it's his.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 然后
Shure: And then...
Alice:这是宇轩的
Alice: This is Yuxuan's.
Katrina:  嗯那写LX LYX
Katrina: Hmm, then write LX, LYX.
Jake: 啊哈哈哈哈
Jake: Ah, hahaha.
Shure:  这这位是谁的人
Shure: Whose person is this?
Lucia: 我露西或者写个l也行哈哈哈
Lucia: It's mine, Lucia, or just write L, haha.
Shure:  啊你要邀请两个是吗
Shure: Ah, are you going to invite someone now?
Alice: 对但是有一个可能来不了
Alice: Yeah, but one might not come.
Shure:  性别
Shure: Gender.
Alice:都是女的呵
Alice: They're all girls, huh
Tasha: 有一个不知道能来不能
Tasha: There's one who might not be able to come
Tasha: 你给我画个星就行了五角星
Tasha: Just draw a star for me, a five-pointed star
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK
Shure:  现在我们有一二三四五六六位嘉宾
Shure: Now we have one, two, three, four, five, six guests
Jake: 嗯呃4-6位嘉宾
Jake: Uh, 4-6 guests
Shure:  对 4-6位
Shure: Yeah, 4-6 guests
Jake:4-6位嘉宾OK
Jake: 4-6 guests, OK
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh
Jake: 我们原来还打算有可能的话
Jake: We originally planned, if possible,
Jake: 去邀请周围的人
Jake: to invite people from around the area
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Jake: 就是或者小红书
Jake: Or use Xiaohongshu (Little Red Book)
Jake: 还是
Jake: Or
Lucia: 是采取挨家挨户敲门询问的方式吗
Lucia: Are we going door-to-door to ask?
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh
Jake:反正
Jake: Anyway
Tasha: 提一篮子鸡蛋比较好
Tasha: Bringing a basket of eggs would be better
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Lucia: 确实如果如
Lucia: Indeed, if they
Lucia: 果就是如果他们来的话可以发鸡蛋什么的
Lucia: if they come, we can give them eggs or something
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah
Shure:  明天咱们这是被举报了
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake: 明天可以拍一段警察的镜头哈哈哈
Jake: Tomorrow we can film a scene with the police, hahaha
Shure:  2邀请邻居
Shure: Invite the neighbors
Shure:  哎这邀字好难写
Shure: Man, this "invite" character is hard to write
Jake: 要不你@吧
Shure:  我觉得也是
Shure: I think so too
Tasha: 带上鸡蛋
Tasha: Bring the eggs
Tasha: 你要是来我就把这一篮送你
Tasha: If you come, I'll give you this basket
Tasha: 你不来就不送
Tasha: If you don't come, no eggs
Tasha: 哈哈隐
Tasha: Haha hidden
Shure:  居
Shure: Neighborhood
Shure:  哎这字
Shure: Man, this character
Shure:  齐白石看着都落泪
Shure: Qi Baishi would cry if he saw this
Alice: 有种复古的感觉
Alice: It has a vintage feel
Shure:  这是我们的plan
Shure: This is our plan
Shure:  存疑plan
Shure: Suspicious plan
Shure:  okay
Shure: Okay
Lucia: 好多问号啊
Lucia: So many question marks
Lucia: 我们好像谜语
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure: the riddle
Shure: The riddle
Shure:  然后我们还还有
Shure: And we still have...
Shure:  还有什么
Shure: What else?
Jake: 呃这是人员
Jake: Uh, this is personnel
Shure:  不对
Shure: No, that's not right
Jake: 呃剧组吧剧组还有5个人
Jake: Uh, the crew, there are still 5 people in the crew
Jake: 然后对总共看
Jake: And yeah, overall, look
Jake: 最后我们要host多少个人
Jake: Finally, how many people do we need to host
Jake: 然后看看这活动在这个人数下
Jake: And see what we should do with this number of people
Jake: 应该整点啥
Jake: What should we do
Alice:角丝
Jake: 给大家拍
Jake: Took a picture for everyone
Lucia: 这没事没事可以技术处理一下吗
Lucia: It's okay, can we fix it with tech?
Jake: 是但是
Jake: Yes, but
Shure: 后期给
Shure: Fix it in post
Jake:后期很麻烦哈哈
Jake: Post-production is troublesome, haha
Shure:  添了多少麻烦
Shure: How much trouble did it cause?
Shure:  OK所以总共one two three four
Shure: Okay, so total, one, two, three, four
Tasha: 4到6 个
Tasha: 4 to 6
Shure: four加五五个
Shure: Four plus five, that's nine
Shure:  这是9
Shure: That's 9
Jake:4加五九
Jake: Four plus five, nine
Jake: 九到11是吧
Jake: Nine to 11, right?
Shure:  9到11 人
Shure: 9 to 11 people
Jake: 9到11 然后各位自己
Jake: 9 to 11, and you all
Shure:  算算上我们是吧
Shure: Count us in, right?
Jake:可以 哎就先写到9-11吧
Jake: Okay, let's just write down 9-11 first
Jake: 9-11
Shure: 9-11 正无穷
Shure: 9-11, positive infinity
Shure:  因为我们可以邀请邻居
Shure: Because we can invite neighbors
Jake: 嗯对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah
Jake: 非常也有无穷的邻居
Jake: A lot of neighbors too
Jake: 也不是正无穷吧 16亿
Jake: Not really positive infinity, 1.6 billion
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Shure:  现在我们我我国人有16亿了吗
Shure: So, do we have 1.6 billion people now?
Jake: 14
Jake: 1.4
Shure: 14吧
Shure: 1.4, right?
Jake:那就14
Jake: Yeah, 1.4.
Shure:  完了这移动的
Shure: Oh man, this is moving.
Jake:报数多了
Jake: Too many numbers.
Jake: 哈哈合适吗
Jake: Haha, is this appropriate?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Jake: 问题不大问题不大
Jake: No big deal, no big deal.
Shure:  一OK
Shure: One OK.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Shure:  然后好人员确定了
Shure: Alright, personnel confirmed.
Shure:  嗯这是第一
Shure: Yeah, this is the first.
Shure:  第一大点的第三
Shure: The third point of the first big thing.
Shure:  下面三个小点人员
Shure: Below are three small personnel points.
Shure:  然后我们还有第二点
Shure: Then we have the second point.
Shure:  要开始活
Shure: To start the work.
Shure:  动内容部分吗
Shure: The content part of the activity?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Shure:  这我觉得是一块硬骨头我们要啃很久
Shure: I think this is a tough nut to crack, we'll have to work on it for a long time.
Shure:  嗯所以我们要直接先来这个吗
Shure: So, should we start with this first?
Jake: 那还有别的吗
Jake: Is there anything else?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  活动内容
Shure: Activity content.
Shure:  大家想想
Shure: Everyone think about it.
Shure:  我记得大家问卷的时候应该是填过的
Shure: I remember everyone filled out the questionnaire, right?
Shure:  嗯是吧
Shure: Yeah, right?
Jake: 是的
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 大家问卷填的是什么来着
Shure: What did everyone put on the questionnaire again?
Shure:  不会都是GPT生成的吧
Shure: They weren't all GPT-generated, right?
Katrina:  不是哈哈哈我自己想的
Jake: 湖南GPT生成的
Jake: Hunan GPT-generated.
Shure:  那既然提到湖南GPT那我们先从
Shure:  Lyx同学
Shure: Lyx, your turn.
Katrina:  哈哈哈我我想是那个就是呃7天
Katrina: Hahaha, I was thinking, like, um, 7 days.
Katrina:  然后每我买那花嘛
Katrina: And then each day I buy flowers.
Katrina:  然后每人一个花瓶
Katrina: And then everyone gets a vase.
Katrina:  然后就相当于醒花一一到2天
Katrina: So, like, the flowers bloom in 1 to 2 days.
Katrina:  然后刚好他一个周期
Katrina: And it fits the cycle perfectly.
Katrina:  就是可以让这花慢慢的开放
Katrina: So you can let this flower bloom slowly.
Katrina:  然后把这个花的花瓣
Katrina: Then take the petals of the flower.
Katrina:  然后做成那种压花
Katrina: And make pressed flowers.
Katrina:  然后就比较环保做成那种明信片
Katrina: It's more eco-friendly to make postcards like that.
Katrina:  还有买了那种亚克力的玻璃
Katrina: I also bought some acrylic glass.
Katrina:  然后就嵌进去
Katrina: Then embed them in.
Katrina:  就是那种比较好看的手工
Katrina: It's a nice handmade craft.
Katrina:  然后也跟植物有关
Katrina: And it's related to plants.
Katrina:  然后原材料又是自己精心养了7天的
Katrina: The raw materials were carefully nurtured by me for 7 days.
Katrina:  然后又觉得形成了一个闭环
Katrina: It feels like a closed loop.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Katrina: 就做了一些周边
Katrina: Made some peripherals.
Katrina:  到时候那一天就可以分发给大家
Katrina: We can distribute them to everyone that day.
Jake: 上才艺
Jake: Show your talent.
Katrina:  那花的在哪
Katrina: Where are the flowers?
Alice:在哪
Alice: Where are they?
Katrina:  花还要醒一的
Katrina: The flowers need to wake up.
Katrina:  因为我看我
Katrina: Because I see...
Katrina:  我刚才想的是种那种什么东西
Katrina: I was thinking about planting something.
Katrina:  符合那种地球世界
Katrina: That fits Earth Day.
Katrina:  地球日他7天基本上发不了芽
Katrina: But it won't sprout in 7 days for Earth Day.
Katrina:  然后我就想是买这种花
Katrina: So I thought about buying these flowers.
Jake:上才艺
Jake: Show your talent.
Katrina: : 直接那个顺丰发过来
Jake:是这个吗
Jake: Is it this one?
Katrina:  云南的花
Katrina: Flowers from Yunnan.
Lucia: 是他好像有两个苞
Lucia: It seems to have two buds.
Katrina:  对我买了芍药啊
Katrina: Yes, I bought peonies.
Jake:不想送了
Jake: I don't want to give them away.
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Katrina:  刚好一些花骨朵就这两天就可以开了
Katrina: Just in time for some flower buds to bloom in these two days.
Lucia: 你要找个剪刀什么的吗
Lucia: Do you need to find scissors or something?
Alice: 剪刀
Alice: Scissors.
Katrina: 直接开始干吗还是说要把后面的列完
Jake: 呃先秀一下
Jake: Uh, show it first.
Shure: 先秀一下
Shure: Show it first.
Jake:先秀一下
Jake: Show it first.
Alice: 剪刀不见了
Alice: The scissors are gone.
Katrina:  我买了好几束来着
Katrina: I bought several bunches.
Shure: 剪刀在这儿呢
Shure: The scissors are here.
Katrina: 还买了康乃馨
Katrina: I also bought some carnations.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Alice: 谢谢
Alice: Thank you.
Jake: 眼神好啊小伙
Jake: Good eye, buddy.
Alice: 刚好我们女孩子比较多哈哈
Alice: Just so happens we have more girls here, haha.
Katrina:  啊这也是
Katrina: Ah, that’s true.
Katrina:  这花瓣就可以做压花
Katrina: You can use these petals for pressed flowers.
Katrina:  然后买了压花器还有那个·干燥剂
Katrina: So I bought a flower press and some desiccants.
Lucia: 这是什么
Lucia: What is this?
Katrina:  这是花这个要养一下
Katrina: These are flowers, they need to air out a bit.
Alice: 这是芍药吗
Alice: Are these peonies?
Katrina:  嗯我买多了我才知道
Katrina: Yeah, I bought too many and then realized.
Katrina:  他说要一到两天才能开花
Katrina: They said it takes one to two days for them to bloom.
Katrina:  然后想时间就差不多
Katrina: So the timing should be just right.
Katrina:  压花就要压个两三天
Katrina: Pressed flowers take two to three days.
Katrina:  然后这个养个两三天
Katrina: And these need to be kept for two to three days.
Lucia: 这是什么百合
Lucia: What kind of lilies are these?
Alice:香雪蓝还是啥
Alice: Are they fresias or what?
Katrina:  什么百合来着百合蓝
Katrina: What kind of lilies... blue lilies.
Tasha: 营养剂泡在水里面加速醒发的
Tasha: Nutrients soaked in water to speed up the blooming.
Alice: 这两个颜色的
Alice: These two colors.
Katrina:  对一个白一个黄
Katrina: Yeah, one white and one yellow.
Katrina:  是一个包裹
Katrina: It was one package.
Katrina:  我看我记得他好像发两个包裹
Katrina: I remember he sent two packages.
Jake: 要不他上我们也上
Jake: If he's going, we should too.
Jake: 才艺你看看哪些是你的
Jake: Check out which talents are yours.
Tasha: 没有我的
Tasha: None of mine.
Jake: 没有你的啊
Jake: None of yours, huh?
Jake: 你没有买这个
Jake: You didn't buy this?
Jake: 外面的快递就只有雨轩的是吧
Jake: The only delivery outside is Yuxuan's, right?
Jake: 还有别人买快递
Jake: Did anyone else buy deliveries?
Lucia: 你们买东西了吗
Lucia: Did you guys buy anything?
Shure:  还没呢还没
Shure: Not yet, not yet.
Jake: 行没问题
Jake: Alright, no problem.
Jake: 都是自带的是吧
Shure:  带资进组
Shure: He brought his own resources.
Shure:  你看这就
Shure: Look, this is it.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Shure: 觉悟
Shure: Awareness.
Katrina:  然后呢就花瓶
Jake: 比划比划
Jake: Show us a bit.
Jake: 就是大概要个什么形式
Jake: Like, what kind of format are we looking at?
Katrina: 形式吗 形式就是我们6个人一人一个花瓶
Katrina: Format? The format is that each of the six of us gets a vase.
Katrina:  我也买好了
Katrina: I've already bought them.
Katrina:  然后大家把这花分分分分了以后养了
Katrina: Then everyone divides the flowers and starts taking care of them.
Katrina:  一一一到两三天
Katrina: In about one to two or three days,
Katrina:  呃他这个就会慢慢全部开了嘛
Katrina: the flowers will start blooming gradually.
Katrina:  开了以后就用这种花瓣或者是
Katrina: Once they bloom, you can use the petals or
Katrina:  我看他们压花
Katrina: I saw people pressing flowers,
Katrina:  就是直接把这个花骨朵花剪下来
Katrina: just cut the buds directly.
Katrina:  然后就直接这样压
Katrina: Then press them directly like this,
Katrina:  他就会变成一个那种平面的
Katrina: and they will become flat.
Katrina:  然后展开的那个花
Katrina: Then the flower will spread out.
Katrina:  然后就可以坐在那种明信片
Katrina: You can put it on a postcard.
Katrina:  我买的那种明信片贺卡
Katrina: I bought postcards and greeting cards.
Katrina:  还有那个包括那个叫什么
Katrina: And also, what's it called...
Katrina:  那种亚克力双层玻璃
Katrina: those acrylic double-layer glass frames.
Katrina:  然后像像一个那种相框就可以
Katrina: It's like a picture frame, so you can
Katrina:  送给别人然后一些叶子啊什么的
Katrina: give it to others with some leaves or other things.
Katrina:  然后当时想的是
Katrina: At that time, I was thinking,
Katrina:  你不是有那个户外活动吗
Katrina: didn't you have that outdoor activity?
Katrina:  我们就可以去捡一些叶子
Katrina: We can pick up some leaves.
Katrina:  然后就把它拼成一幅画一样的
Katrina: Then put them together like a picture.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yes.
Katrina:  然后书签也有然后就大家自己做着玩
Katrina: Also, we can make bookmarks, and everyone can have fun making them.
Katrina:  然后最后一天
Katrina: On the last day,
Katrina:  因为想这种形式
Katrina: because of this format,
Katrina:  这种就邀请什么各种好朋友啊什么的
Katrina: we can invite various friends.
Katrina:  就可以你自己做的自己养的
Katrina: Then you can give what you made and grew to others, which is nice.
Katrina:  然后分发给大家就挺好
Katrina: It also fits the seven-day cycle.
Katrina:  然后也比较符合7天这个周期嘛
Katrina: And it suits the seven-day period well.
Alice: 嗯要不先给他醒了吧
Alice: Hmm, how about waking him up first?
Katrina:  嗯可以啊今天我肯今天是一定要
Katrina: Hmm, sure. Today, I definitely will.
Jake: 先聊吧这个回头下一个
Jake: Let's talk first, and then we'll get to the next one.
Katrina:  行下一个下一个谁
Katrina: Okay, who's next?
Tasha: 下一个
Tasha: Next one.
Katrina: 我来弄这个
Katrina: I'll handle this.
Katrina:  下一个谁来
Katrina: Who's next?
Shure: 下一个 路路亚同学啊
Shure: Next is Luluya.
Katrina:  我
Katrina: Me.
Shure: 露西
Shure: Lucia
Lucia: 啊其实就是我的构思
Lucia: Ah, actually, this is my idea.
Lucia: 也跟DIY是有关系的
Lucia: It's related to DIY.
Lucia: 对我刚我刚开始想的是
Lucia: Yeah, at first, I was thinking
Lucia: 就是可以因为是世界地球日
Lucia: Since it's Earth Day,
Lucia: 所以我想就是做一点环保一点的东西
Lucia: I wanted to make something more environmentally friendly.
Lucia: 就我不知道大家有没有做过水母灯
Lucia: I don't know if you guys have made jellyfish lamps.
Lucia: 就这两年在景区还挺火的
Lucia: They've been quite popular in scenic areas these past two years.
Lucia: 呃就是长得像水母一样的一个小灯
Lucia: Um, it's a small lamp that looks like a jellyfish.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 然后这个东西它原本是有材料包的
Lucia: So this thing originally comes with a material kit.
Lucia: 就是可以直接在网上买材料包做
Lucia: You can just buy the material kit online.
Lucia: 但是我就是我想的是
Lucia: But what I was thinking is
Lucia: 就是既然是世界地球日的话
Lucia: Since it's Earth Day,
Lucia: 我之前在网上刷到过一个教程
Lucia: I saw a tutorial online before
Lucia: 就是可以用那个奶茶杯盖
Lucia: That uses a milk tea cup lid as the base.
Lucia: 然后以它作为一个主体
Lucia: And then you add some ribbons
Lucia: 然后就是再加一些丝带
Lucia: Or beads or something.
Lucia: 或者串珠之类的
Lucia: Um, I don't know if we have a hot glue gun.
Lucia: 呃我不知道咱们这有没有热热胶枪
Lucia: If we don't,
Lucia: 如果没有的话
Lucia: We could find a substitute
Lucia: 可以后面看有没有什么替代的
Lucia: Or we could buy one.
Lucia: 或者说买一个也行
Lucia: And then everyone could make one of these little lamps.
Lucia: 然后就是大家一起
Lucia: They look really nice.
Lucia: 就是每个人都做一个这样的小灯
Lucia: So that's one idea.
Lucia: 就是它还挺好看的
Lucia: Another idea is also
Lucia: 然后这是其中一个设想
Lucia: Kind of about low-carbon and recycling.
Lucia: 还有一个就是也是
Lucia: Have you guys made cardboard dogs before?
Lucia: 有点这种怎么说呢
Lucia: They were really popular recently.
Lucia: 低碳和循环利用的
Lucia: You can put them at the door.
Lucia: 就是大家有没有做过纸箱小狗
Lucia: The good thing about cardboard dogs is
Lucia: 就前段时间特别火那个啊
Lucia: If you want to keep it simple,
Katrina:  可以放在那个
Katrina: You can put it at the...
Lucia: 对然后可以放在门口
Lucia: Yeah, you can put it at the entrance.
Lucia: 然后纸箱小狗的好处就是
Lucia: And the good thing about cardboard dogs is
Lucia: 如果想要很简单做一下的话
Lucia: If you want to make it simple,
Lucia: 就拿纸箱简单剪一下
Lucia: You just cut the cardboard,
Lucia: 然后画一个小狗头粘上就可以
Lucia: Draw a dog's head, and stick it on.
Lucia: 如果想要复杂一点的话
Lucia: If you want it to be more complex,
Lucia: 就是也有一些
Lucia: 就是复杂点就需要多剪几个
Lucia: a bit more complicated and need to be cut into several pieces.
Lucia: 然后做成一个大的
Lucia: Then put together into a big one.
Lucia: 我之前看到有人做过杜宾
Lucia: I saw someone make a Doberman before.
Lucia: 但是那个我没做过就是
Lucia: But I haven't made that one.
Lucia: 但是就是看了一下教程
Lucia: I just watched the tutorial.
Lucia: 好像也挺简单的
Lucia: It seems pretty simple.
Lucia: 只要画一下卡纸就能很容易剪出来
Lucia: Just draw on the cardboard and it's easy to cut out.
Shure:  咱们最不缺的就是纸箱
Shure: The one thing we have plenty of is cardboard.
Shure:  所以我觉得这个
Shure: So I think this
Lucia: 对我当时想的也是
Lucia: Yeah, I was thinking the same.
Lucia: 在咱们这里到时候肯定会有很多纸箱
Lucia: We’ll definitely have a lot of cardboard here.
Lucia: 如果说就能直接使用的话
Lucia: If we can use it directly,
Lucia: 就还挺环保的
Lucia: it's quite eco-friendly.
Lucia: 就也很契合世界地球日这个主题
Lucia: It fits well with the Earth Day theme.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: start
Lucia: 然后最后还有一个想法
Lucia: And one last idea,
Lucia: 但是这个想法实施起来就比较困难
Lucia: but it's a bit hard to execute.
Lucia: 我本来想的是
Lucia: What I originally thought was
Lucia: 可能大家可以简单的排一个小短剧
Lucia: 或者之类的
Lucia: Or something like that.
Lucia: 对因为我之前跟我小伙伴有说
Lucia: Yeah, because I talked to my friends earlier.
Lucia: 我们今天拍一些微电影这种
Lucia: We were thinking about filming some short films today.
Lucia: 但是如果要排一个小短剧的话
Lucia: But if we want to do a short skit,
Lucia: 就是我现在暂时还没有想到一个现成
Lucia: I don't have a ready-made script right now.
Lucia: 我们目前就拿来用的剧本
Lucia: We don’t have a script we can use immediately.
Lucia: 因为咱们时间比较短
Lucia: Since our time is quite limited.
Lucia: 就如果要现在去编的话
Lucia: If we write one now,
Lucia: 可能就不太来得及
Lucia: we probably won't have enough time.
Lucia: 就如果大家有想到什么
Lucia: If you have any ideas,
Lucia: 你们以前看到过的短视频之类的
Lucia: like short videos you've seen before,
Lucia: 这种也可以
Lucia: those would work too.
Lucia: 就如果有个现成的剧本
Lucia: If there's a ready-made script,
Lucia: 我觉得咱们可以尝试拍一下对
Lucia: I think we could give it a shot.
Shure:  OK 好
Shure: OK, sure.
Lucia: 这个是目前暂时的想法
Lucia: That's the current idea.
Shure:  这是Lucia
Shure: This is Lucia.
Shure:  这是
Shure: This is...
Shure:  露西亚哈哈
Shure: Lucia, haha.
Lucia: 哦我们两个名字好像
Lucia: Oh, our names are so similar.
Katrina: 真
Alice: 你把她名写反了哎
Alice: You wrote her name backwards.
Jake:加一道加一道
Jake: Add one more, add one more.
Katrina:  刘宇轩哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: 直接加一道就行
Alice: Just add one more.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina:  完了就是那个XY完染色体的
Jake: 对对对变异
Jake: Yeah, yeah, mutation.
Shure:  好家伙这俩你都有
Shure: Wow, you have both?
Shure:  是吗哈哈哈哈
Shure: Really? Hahaha.
Shure:   Tasha.
Shure:  Tasha.
Tasha: OK上我的道具拿出来哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Okay, bring out my props, hahaha.
Jake: 上道具BGM
Jake: Bring out the props BGM.
Shure:  当当当当当当当
Shure: Dun dun dun dun dun.
Shure:  当当当
Shure: Dun dun dun.
Lucia: 此处应有背景音乐
Shure:  他的道具为什么在你的行李箱里
Shure: Why are his props in your suitcase?
Jake: 啊因为又是代言人
Jake: Ah, because he's also the spokesperson.
Tasha: 不就这个
Tasha: Isn't it just this?
Tasha: 就这个啊
Tasha: Just this one.
Tasha: 你怎么没拆
Tasha: Why didn't you open it?
Tasha: 我去拿个现成的吧
Tasha: I'll go get a ready-made one.
Tasha: 你把培养皿拿出来吧
Tasha: You take out the petri dish.
Shure:  培养皿
Shure: Petri dish.
Jake:培养皿
Jake: Petri dish.
Jake: 培养皿买了
Jake: Bought the petri dish.
Jake: 但是不一定到了
Jake: But it might not have arrived.
Jake: 不一定到哈
Jake: Might not have arrived, huh.
Jake: 我看一下
Jake: Let me check.
Katrina:  买了康乃馨
Katrina: Bought carnations.
Katrina:  这个叫叫叫
Katrina: This is called, called, called...
Katrina:  芍药康乃馨
Katrina: Peonies, carnations.
Katrina:  直播间买的
Katrina: Bought in the live stream.
Katrina:  哈哈好好看呀
Katrina: Haha, looks so nice.
Lucia: 直播间买
Lucia: Bought in the live stream.
Lucia: 顺丰秒送
Lucia: Delivered by SF Express.
Katrina:  哎他昨天花瓶昨天也到了
Katrina: Hey, the vase also arrived yesterday.
Jake: 对到了
Jake: Yeah, it did.
Katrina:  这都是我们的快递
Katrina: All our packages.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 好像没有别的种类
Tasha: Seems like there aren't other types.
Katrina:  可以装在这种里面
Katrina: You can put it in this.
Katrina:  我看一下
Katrina: Let me take a look.
Katrina:  弄出来特别漂亮
Katrina: It looks really beautiful.
Shure:  你这是相框
Katrina:  对就把花夹在里面
Katrina: Yeah, just press the flowers in it.
Katrina:  还有一些叶子什么的可以摆在家里
Katrina: You can also put some leaves and stuff to decorate your home.
Katrina:  这确实这怎么雾蒙蒙的
Katrina: This really looks kind of hazy.
Katrina:  他中间应该夹了一层东西
Katrina: There must be something layered in the middle.
Jake: 被嫌弃了
Jake: It's disliked.
Jake: 我应该拆吗
Jake: Should I take it apart?
Tasha: 然后哈哈
Tasha: Then haha.
Tasha: 就是这是
Tasha: It's just this.
Tasha: 自己设计的一些种子纸
Tasha: Some seed paper I designed myself.
Tasha: 就是把种子放在这个纸里面
Tasha: It's like putting seeds in this paper.
Tasha: 这个纸是用废弃的咖啡渣
Tasha: This paper is made from used coffee grounds.
Tasha: 呃一些纸
Tasha: Uh, some paper.
Tasha: 然后做成那种纸浆
Tasha: Then turning it into pulp.
Tasha: 然后纸浆里面有那种乳种子
Tasha: And there are seeds in the pulp.
Tasha: 都是用的太阳花种子
Tasha: I used sunflower seeds.
Tasha: 太阳花种子它比较容易发芽
Tasha: Sunflower seeds are easy to sprout.
Tasha: 然后如果用培养皿水培的话
Tasha: And if you use a petri dish with water culture,
Tasha: 大概5天左右就可以发芽
Tasha: They can sprout in about 5 days.
Tasha: 然后做了一些种类的
Tasha: So I made some types.
Tasha: 算世界地球日吗
Tasha: Is it for Earth Day?
Jake: 那可地球了
Jake: Totally for Earth.
Katrina:  这是你自己做的吗
Katrina: Did you make this yourself?
Katrina:  好厉害
Katrina: That's amazing.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha.: Mm-hmm.
Katrina:  好厉害
Katrina: So awesome.
Tasha: 然后做了5种
Tasha: Then I made five types.
Tasha: 地球的
Tasha: Earth-themed.
Tasha: 然后做了两种很简单的
Tasha: And then two very simple ones.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Katrina: 但是你是原创哎
Katrina: But you are the original creator.
Jake: 有点强
Jake: That's quite strong.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Jake: 种子片
Jake: Seed paper.
Jake: 种子片嗯
Jake: Seed paper, mm-hmm.
Shure:  种子片
Shure: Seed paper
Jake:种子片
Jake: Seed paper
Tasha: 嗯然后这样就比较环保
Tasha: Yeah, and this way it's more eco-friendly.
Lucia: 嗯真的很环保
Lucy: Yeah, it's really eco-friendly.
Lucia: 真的很环保
Lucia: It's really eco-friendly.
Katrina:  而且还极具美感好吗
Katrina: Plus, it's aesthetically pleasing, right?
Katrina:  1234 好
Katrina: 1234, okay.
Jake: 那你自己设计的
Jake: Did you design it yourself?
Alice:嗯对我也去拿一下我的东西
Alice: Yeah, I'm going to grab my stuff too.
Jake: 是画的图吗
Jake: Is it a drawing?
Tasha: 啊这很简单了
Tasha: Oh, this is simple.
Tasha: 就找一些logo
Tasha: Just find some logos.
Tasha: 然后这个logo一找
Tasha: Once you find the logo,
Tasha: 写个字框个框就行了
Tasha: You just write some text and frame it.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Jake: 挺好的挺好
Jake: Pretty good, pretty good.
Lucia: 好厉害
Lucia: Amazing.
Katrina:  种子卡片
Katrina: Seed cards.
Katrina:  然后呢就是
Katrina: And then, it's like...
Alice: 嗯买了一个拼图
Alice: Yeah, I bought a puzzle.
Alice: 是一个呃大底层是一个圆的
Alice: It's a big round base.
Alice: 然后它那个里面是这种的
Alice: And inside, it's like this.
Alice: 就是各种动物的那种
Alice: It's like various animals.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:然后你看你能不能
Alice: And then you see if you can...
Alice: 就是一个比较难的一个拼图
Alice: It's a rather difficult puzzle.
Alice: 然后有很多种动物
Alice: And it has many kinds of animals.
Alice: 我想的就是呃你去尽力的往里面拼
Alice: I think you just try to fit them in.
Alice: 就是我觉得这个拼图就给人一种
Alice: I feel like this puzzle gives a sense of...
Alice: 我们在地球上
Alice: Us on Earth...
Alice: 可以和谐共处的那个感觉
Alice: Coexisting in harmony.
Katrina: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Alice: 然后你不一定全都能拼上
Alice: And you might not be able to fit them all.
Alice: 但是因为这种不是那个严丝合缝
Alice: Because it's not perfectly seamless.
Alice: 不是特别完全严丝合缝
Alice: It's not completely seamless.
Alice: 就是说你可以拼多一点
Alice: So you can fit more or less.
Alice: 也可以拼少一点
Alice: And I was thinking...
Alice: 然后我就想
Alice: It might be a little game.
Alice: 呃可能就是一个小的游戏吧
Alice: Maybe just a small game.
Jake: 头头发
Jake: Hair.
Jake: 呵呵呵
Alice:对
Alice: Yeah
Jake:要不
Jake: How about
Jake: 要不夹进去
Jake: How about we clip it in
Katrina:  有没有夹子
Katrina: Do we have any clips?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Alice: 然后就是
Alice: And then
Alice: 我就想给参与者就是一个小奖品
Alice: I was thinking of giving the participants a little prize
Alice: 就是一颗水仙种球
Alice: Like a daffodil bulb
Alice: 因为这个水仙种球它好养
Alice: Because these daffodil bulbs are so easy to grow
Alice: 就是呃
Alice: Even, uh
Alice: 在我的那种植物杀手朋友身上
Alice: My friends who usually kill plants
Alice: 试验过了
Alice: Have tried it
Alice: 他都能养活的东西
Alice: And they managed to keep it alive
Alice: 然后这个花开出来也特别的好看
Alice: And the flowers are really beautiful
Alice: 然后还有清香的味道
Alice: Plus, they have a lovely fragrance
Alice: 并且你看着他一天天长大
Alice: And you get to watch it grow every day
Alice: 你很有那种参与自然的感觉
Alice: It makes you feel really connected to nature
Alice: 对所以这就是我的想法
Alice: So that's my idea
Alice: 但是水仙球还没买
Alice: But I haven't bought the bulbs yet
Alice: 但是我有
Alice: 我知道有一家质量特别好的
Alice: 我养过的就是
Alice: 有需要他可以直接买过来
Jake: 好
Jake: 仙球
Shure:  活动内容现在有4个
Shure:  到谁了
Alice: 我写吧
Alice: 不是到我了吗
Shure:  野生动物拼图
Katrina:  哎我还想让我第一天吃海底捞
Katrina:  送了我一个种草莓的那个盆栽
Katrina:  也可以种一下
Jake:海底捞
Tasha: 那那个豌豆还可以种
Katrina:  对
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Katrina:  海底捞就最近不是跟樱桃小丸子联名
Katrina: Recently, Hai Di Lao collaborated with Chibi Maruko-chan.
Katrina:  点他那个东西他就送你那个盆栽
Katrina: If you order their special item, they give you a bonsai plant.
Lucia: 哦这么好
Lucia: Oh, that's so nice.
Katrina:  送我草莓
Katrina:  我说他咋知道我要过来种东西
Katrina: I was wondering how he knew I was coming to plant something.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  我当时本来想买盆栽来着
Katrina: I was planning to buy a potted plant at that time.
Katrina:  想盆栽要一个月才能发芽
Katrina: But it takes a month for a potted plant to sprout.
Jake: 走上海边种树去
Jake: Let's go plant trees by the seaside.
Shure:  然后到我了
Shure: Then it's my turn.
Jake:到您了
Jake: Your turn.
Shure:  我的是一个啧
Shure: Mine is a...
Shure:  一个类似于二手拍卖的
Shure: It's kind of like a second-hand auction.
Shure:  一个一个一个一个一个一个一个想法
Shure: An idea, an idea, an idea, an idea.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Shure: 我不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Shure:  大家平时会不会去一些什么
Shure: Do you guys usually go to places like...
Shure:  比如说小小小酒馆啊
Shure: For example, small pubs,
Shure:  或者是咖啡店
Shure: or coffee shops,
Shure:  就那种比较有烟火气的地方
Shure: those kinds of places with a lively atmosphere?
Shure:  然后之前那个
Shure: And before that,
Shure:  北京有一个连锁的精酿啤酒
Shure: there was a chain of craft beer places in Beijing
Shure:  叫跳海
Shure: called Jumping Sea.
Katrina: 哦我知道在什刹海那是不是
Katrina: Oh, I know, is it by Shichahai?
Shure:  对什刹海应该是这个吧
Shure: Yes, Shichahai, I think so.
Jake: 然后指的是这个吗
Jake: Then you're talking about that one?
Shure:  其其他城市也有
Shure: They have other locations in other cities too.
Shure:  什么市场也有
Shure: Some markets too.
Shure:  然后他们前两天大榕寺开业的时候
Shure: And a few days ago, when Da Rong Temple opened,
Shure:  他们搞了一个
Shure: they held an event,
Shure:  就是类似于这个拍卖的
Shure: kind of like an auction,
Shure:  一个一个一个形式吧
Shure: a similar format.
Shure:  然后就是
Shure: So,
Shure:  嗯
Shure: hmm,
Shure:  他们当时是你喝酒会给你一个币
Shure: they gave you a token if you drank beer.
Jake: 知道吗
Jake: Really?
Shure: 然后用这个币
Shure: And you could use that token
Shure:  来买大家的一些任何的东西
Shure: to buy anything from anyone.
Shure:  可以是一个是是一个诗集
Shure: It could be a collection of poems,
Shure:  可以是一个故事
Shure: it could be a story,
Shure:  然后也可以是一个
Shure: or it could be a
Shure:  就是真实存在的一个物品
Shure: tangible item.
Shure:  然后就每人
Shure: Then each person
Shure:  就是那个每个物品都做一个小的PPT
Shure: will make a small PPT for each item
Shure:  然后展示出来
Shure: and present it.
Katrina: 啊还要做ppt吗
Katrina: Ah, do we have to make a PPT?
Shure:  然后然后然后哈哈哈哈
Shure: Then, then, then, hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 这是工作狂游戏吗
Lucia: Is this a workaholic game?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure: 啊不然后然
Shure: Ah, no, then
Shure:  后然后
Shure: and then
Shure:  然后然后
Shure: then then
Shure:  然后就是一个拍卖吧
Shure: Then there will be an auction.
Shure:  然后我们可以怎么样呢
Shure: And we can do what?
Shure:  就是来的这些嘉宾
Shure: The guests who come
Shure:  然后大家一人分享一个故事
Shure: will each share a story
Shure:  或者是呃
Shure: or, um,
Shure:  事故也好
Shure: an incident,
Shure:  故事也好
Shure: a story,
Shure:  然后来我们给评定
Shure: then we will evaluate
Shure:  觉得这个故事怎么样
Shure: how good the story is.
Jake: 值多少个币是吧
Jake: How many coins is it worth?
Shure:  对值多少个币
Shure: Yes, how many coins.
Shure:  然后给他
Shure: Then give them
Shure:  然后这个币
Shure: and these coins
Tasha: 像什么
Tasha: Like what?
Tasha: 一个故事换一根藤条的那种
Tasha: Like exchanging a story for a cane?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  然后这个币就用来拍卖
Shure: Then these coins will be used for the auction
Shure:  接下来这些嘉宾带来的二手物品
Shure: for the second-hand items brought by the guests
Shure:  以及是我们就是闲置的一些二手物品
Shure: as well as some of our own unused second-hand items.
Shure:  然后来进行这样的一个交换
Shure: Then we can do this kind of exchange.
Shure:  就是
Shure: It's
Shure:  也是跟这个环保理念比较比较挂钩的
Shure: also quite in line with the environmental protection concept.
Shure:  行大概就是这个样子
Shure: Alright, that's about it.
Jake:妙啊
Jake: Brilliant!
Katrina:  就是讲故事
Katrina: So, telling stories
Katrina:  换了币然后就可以购买
Katrina: to get coins, then you can buy
Katrina:  购买他们自己带来的闲置物品嘛
Katrina: buy the unused items they brought, right?
Shure:  每个人拍
Shure: Everyone auctions
Shure:  拍卖就是比如说我
Shure: An auction is like, for example, if I...
Shure:  我要卖一个什么东西
Shure: I want to sell something...
Shure:  然后我上来讲一下这个东西
Shure: Then I come up and talk about this item...
Shure:  然后我认为他的起拍价大概多少
Shure: And I think its starting price is roughly...
Shure:  然后拍到这个钱
Shure: Then it gets auctioned off for that amount...
Shure:  是给到那个拍卖的那个人的
Shure: The money goes to the person auctioning it...
Shure:  然后他也流通过去那个货币
Shure: And they circulate that currency...
Shure:  然后我拿着这些货币
Shure: Then I take that money...
Shure:  我可以再去拍卖
Shure: And I can go auction again...
Katrina:  你再去买别的
Katrina: You buy other stuff again...
Shure:  对剩下的
Shure: Yeah, the rest of it...
Alice: 反正就是换了一种交流的货币
Alice: It's basically just a different way of exchanging currency...
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Haha...
Katrina:  你构建了我们整个的经济体系
Katrina:  哈哈哈货币流通
Katrina: Haha, currency circulation...
Tasha: OK那我就看他这个行
Tasha: OK, then I’ll see if it works...
Katrina: 我们都是那个市场的内容
Shure:  啊对可以把
Shure: Yeah, you can...
Shure:  这些一起
Shure: Put these together...
Katrina: 我们都是我们都是搞
Katrina: We're all doing this...
Tasha: 赚币的
Tasha: Making money...
Katrina:  他是他是搞货币流通的
Katrina: He's the one circulating currency...
Lucia: 可以做一些手工艺品
Lucia: We can make some crafts...
Lucia: 用来用来拍卖
Lucia: To auction off...
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes...
Katrina: 可以啊
Katrina: Sure...
Katrina:  就我们做这个
Katrina: We'll do that...
Jake:平台方
Jake: Platform side...
Katrina:  也可以
Katrina: We can...
Jake:平台方和小店
Jake: Platform side and small shops...
Jake: 小店家
Jake: Small shop owners...
Katrina: 对哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Yes, hahaha...
Shure:  今天就是这样的形式
Shure: That's the format for today...
Tasha: 这是我的商品
Tasha: This is my product...
Tasha: 我要拍卖了嘿嘿嘿嘿
Tasha: I'm going to auction it off, hehe...
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha...
Shure:  还有什么想法吗
Shure: Any other thoughts?
Shure:  大家
Shure: Everyone?
Katrina: 我看看啊
Katrina: Let me see...
Katrina:  在那一天邀请他
Katrina: Inviting him on that day...
Katrina:  们过来这是我们准备的一些嗯东东西
Katrina: Hey everyone, this is some of the stuff we've prepared.
Katrina:  那怎么招待他们要不要搞一点什么
Katrina: How should we entertain them? Should we do something special?
Katrina:  就像我我我经常我们学校草坪发
Katrina: Like, I often...
Katrina:  他们会自己调酒
Katrina: They mix their own drinks.
Katrina:  就自己自己
Katrina: Just on their own.
Katrina:  人多的时候就有点像那种小party一样
Katrina: When there are more people, it feels like a small party.
Katrina: 可以在外面
Katrina: It can be outside.
Shure:  啊我可以可以给大家冲咖啡
Shure: Ah, I can make coffee for everyone.
Shure:  我那有有一套手冲的东西
Shure: I have a set of pour-over coffee equipment.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina:  对就是可以请大家喝点东西
Katrina: Yeah, we can offer everyone some drinks.
Shure:  笑的这么开心
Shure: Why are you laughing so happily?
Jake: 突然开心了起来
Jake: Suddenly so happy.
Lucia: 支持
Lucy: I support it.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Katrina: 就表演
Katrina: Just perform.
Shure: c加a coffee and alcohol
Shure: C plus A, coffee and alcohol.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 可以吧
Shure: Is that okay?
Katrina:  对那就是整个活动
Katrina: Yeah, that's the whole event.
Katrina:  那一天大概持续多长时间
Katrina: How long will it last that day?
Jake: 一下午呗
Jake: The whole afternoon.
Katrina:  一下午
Katrina: The whole afternoon.
Katrina:  嗯那就给他们提供一些饮品就够了吧
Katrina: Hmm, then just providing some drinks should be enough, right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 先饮品然后我们就有点像
Katrina: First drinks, then we can...
Katrina:  这这算市集部分
Katrina: This part is for the city.
Katrina:  然后饮品部分也有了
Katrina: Then we also have the drinks part covered.
Katrina:  那是不是还要什么节目啊您之前
Katrina: Do we need any programs? You mentioned...
Jake: 嗯对可以
Jake: Hmm, yeah, we can.
Jake: 嗯或者最后一天应该是从中午
Jake: Or, on the last day, it should be from noon.
Jake: 中午管不管饭
Jake: Are we providing lunch?
Jake: 这个另说
Jake: That's another thing.
Jake: 也可以管也可以不管共多少个人
Jake: We can or we can't. How many people in total?
Katrina:  好像
Katrina: Seems like...
Katrina:  不用管饭但是可以请他做一点点甜的
Katrina: We don't need to provide lunch, but we can offer some sweets.
Jake: 对对对下午茶
Jake: Yeah, yeah, afternoon tea.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Right.
Jake:嗯对那就是不用管饭
Jake: Yeah, so no lunch needed.
Jake: 大家吃完饭过来
Jake: Everyone can come after lunch.
Jake: 然后时间线我们捏一下
Jake: Let's adjust the timeline a bit.
Jake: 如果是下午开始两点比如说或者3点
Jake: If we start in the afternoon, like at 2 PM or 3 PM...
Jake: 3点一直干到晚上之类的
Jake: ...and go on until the evening or so.
Katrina:  可以干到晚上但是天气怎么样
Katrina: We can go until the evening, but what about the weather?
Jake: 这个就不知道了
Jake: That, I’m not sure about.
Katrina: 我看会不会下雨
Katrina: I'll check if it's going to rain.
Katrina:  不下雨的话如果像今天这种天的话
Katrina: If it doesn't rain, and the weather is like today...
Katrina:  弄到晚上还是挺漂亮的
Katrina: ...it would be really nice to go until the evening.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 对今天下午的话
Jake: Yeah, if it’s this afternoon...
Jake: 这个小院子应该也挺舒服的
Jake: ...this little yard should be quite comfortable.
Jake: 你还还可以烧烤
Jake: You can even have a barbecue.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yeah.
Jake: 买签了吗
Jake: Did you buy the skewers?
Shure:  还没呢
Shure: Not yet.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 我今天一起购入
Shure: I'll get them today.
Jake:好的
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 还要买碳的
Jake: We also need to buy some charcoal.
Shure: 签碳肉这些
Shure: Sign the carbon meat ones.
Jake:嗯嗯
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Shure:  其实就是外卖都有其实可以当日达的
Shure: Actually, most delivery services can do same-day delivery.
Jake: 行行
Jake: Alright, alright.
Katrina:  21号
Katrina: The 21st.
Shure:  大家平时厨艺如何
Shure: How's everyone's cooking skills usually?
Shure:  就是会使用刀吗
Shure: Can you handle a knife?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 会啊
Tasha: Yeah, I can.
Katrina: 我还行呵呵
Katrina: I'm okay, hehe.
Jake: 会比较会使用
Jake: I'm pretty good with it.
Shure:  能切个肉什么的吗
Shure: Can you cut meat and stuff?
Jake: 能切都能切吧
Jake: Yeah, everyone can cut, right?
Jake: 都能切
Jake: We all can.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Jake:各位都能切了
Jake: Everyone can cut.
Shure:  有大家这句话我就放心了
Shure: Hearing that puts me at ease.
Jake: 因为你不切
Jake: Because you don't cut.
Lucia: 稍微冷藏一下
Lucia: Just chill it a bit.
Lucia: 然后拿出来稍微放一会的时候好切
Lucia: Then take it out and let it sit for a bit, then it’s easier to cut.
Lucia: 嗯如果是软的肉我不是很会切
Lucia: Hmm, if it's soft meat, I'm not very good at cutting it.
Lucia: 就已经化好的那种
Lucia: The kind that's already defrosted.
Shure: 明白
Shure: Got it.
Shure: 行
Shure: Okay.
Jake: 行可以烤是吧
Jake: So it can be grilled, right?
Shure:  可以烤
Shure: It can be grilled.
Jake:长春烤串
Jake: Changchun skewers.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina:  其实调酒好像就是买买一点那种
Katrina: Actually, for making cocktails, you just buy a bit of...
Shure: 啤酒
Shure: Beer.
Katrina:  对然后搞一点冰块
Katrina: Yeah, and then get some ice cubes.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Shure:  冰块的话
Shure: About ice cubes...
Katrina:  哎我现在前面我们走两步
Katrina: Hey, let's walk a few steps ahead.
Katrina:  不是有个咖啡厅
Katrina: Isn't there a cafe there?
Katrina:  能不能问他们借点冰块
Katrina: Can we ask them for some ice?
Katrina:  就不用自己买制冰机了
Katrina: So we don't have to buy an ice maker.
Shure:  可以
Shure: Sure.
Katrina: 我们花钱买点冰块
Katrina: We can pay for some ice.
Shure:  那边有咖啡厅吗
Shure: There's a cafe there?
Katrina:  对啊昨天停车那位置
Katrina: Yeah, where we parked yesterday.
Lucia: 如果我们要求不那么高的话
Lucia: If we're not too picky...
Lucia: 就是买一个冰膜然后自己冻一下
Lucia: We can just buy an ice mold and freeze it ourselves.
Lucia: 也可以啊
Lucia: That works too.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Lucia: 只不过就是冻出来可能没有
Lucia: But the ice might not be as...
Katrina:  哎我们有
Katrina:  我们有冰箱
Katrina: We have a fridge.
Katrina:  就买个那个模具倒点水
Katrina: Just buy a mold and pour in some water.
Katrina:  前天晚上冻一下
Katrina: Freeze it overnight.
Alice: 用蒸馏水就行
Alice: Use distilled water.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:就煮过煮沸的水
Alice: Just boiled water.
Lucia: 哦可以
Lucia: Oh, that works.
Shure:  蒸馏水对
Shure: Distilled water, right.
Shure:  可还行呵呵呵
Shure: That works too, haha.
Shure:  我们到底是在搞什么
Shure: What are we even doing?
Shure:  搞实验了是吗
Shure: Running experiments?
Katrina:  那他整整体的时间流程呢
Katrina: So what's the overall timeline?
Jake: 比如说我们从入场3点3点开始吧
Jake: For example, let's start at 3 o'clock when we enter.
Katrina:  几点到几点干什么
Katrina: What time to what time do we do what?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 因为就5个人
Katrina: Because there are only 5 of us.
Katrina:  就有一点像那种市集
Katrina: It feels a bit like a market.
Katrina:  但是那种市集一般都是比较大
Katrina: But those markets are usually bigger.
Katrina:  然后大家随意逛
Katrina: And everyone just walks around.
Katrina:  但是我们这个地方比较小
Katrina: But our place is pretty small.
Katrina:  那你肯定要规定一定的时间干什么
Katrina: So you definitely need to set specific times for things.
Katrina:  一定的时间干什么
Katrina: Specific times for things.
Katrina:  要不然容易他们一下就看完了
Katrina: Otherwise, they might finish everything too quickly.
Jake: 对你的拍卖可以占一点时间
Jake: Right, your auction can take up some time.
Jake: 看占多长时间
Jake: Let's see how long it takes.
Jake: 然后
Jake: Then...
Jake: 唉
Jake: Sigh...
Jake: 就这些准备都是我们这几天准备对吧
Jake: All these preparations are done by us these days, right?
Jake: 然后别的耗时间的短剧
Jake: And other time-consuming short plays.
Jake: 跳舞吗哈哈哈
Jake: Dancing, haha.
Lucia:  哈哈我一个人跳吗
Lucia: Haha, am I dancing alone?
Katrina:  可以排一个简单的
Katrina: We can choreograph a simple one.
Katrina: 我也可以
Katrina: I can do it too.
Jake: 也可以跳
Katrina:  可以排个稍微简单点的
Katrina: We can choreograph a slightly simpler one.
Jake:硕也可以跳
Jake: Shure can dance too.
Lucia: 哦那也行对
Lucia: Oh, that works too, right.
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Lucia: 你如果有现成的剧本的话
Lucia: If you have a ready-made script.
Katrina:  我们可以排一个哈哈哈
Katrina: We can shoot a video, haha.
Shure:  演其实有有点小尬
Shure: Acting is actually a bit awkward.
Tasha:  嗯不如跳舞
Tasha: Hmm, dancing might be better.
Katrina:  因为那个音乐放上了
Katrina: Because when the music plays.
Tasha:  不如跳舞
Tasha: Dancing might be better.
Alice: 谈恋爱不如跳舞哈哈哈哈
Alice: Dating or dancing, haha.
Shure:  不如跳舞
Shure: Dancing might be better.
Shure:  捋一下时间线吧
Shure: Let's sort out the timeline.
Lucia: 可是跳舞的话戴眼镜会掉耶
Lucia: But if we dance, my glasses might fall off.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 还戴眼镜那时候
Shure: Still wearing glasses then?
Shure:  那我们可以挑点简单的
Shure: We can choose something simpler.
Shure:  蘑菇蘑菇哎
Shure: Mushrooms, mushrooms, hey!
Lucia:  我们可以跳抖音上的那种
Lucia: We could do one of those TikTok dances.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  这个听我说
Shure: Listen to me.
Shure:  谢谢你
Shure: Thank you.
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 抖音上就大家都可以一起挑
Lucia: On TikTok, everyone can join in.
Lucia: 就是排的时间也会短一些对吧
Lucia: And it doesn't take as long to set up, right?
Lucia: 也没有什么比较大的动作
Lucia: Plus, the moves aren't too complicated.
Lucia: 戴眼镜也不影响
Lucia: Wearing glasses won't affect it.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure:  捋下时间线
Shure: Let's go over the timeline.
Tasha: 可拍满100个硬币
Tasha: We could shoot for 100 coins.
Tasha: 哈哈哈啊
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina:  你那个
Katrina: You know...
Tasha: 没事
Tasha: It's fine.
Tasha: 我只是觉得应该拍卖10个银币
Tasha: I just think we should auction 10 silver coins.
Jake:哦好好可以买
Jake: Oh, okay, we can buy them.
Katrina:  哦哦不对
Katrina: Oh no, wait.
Katrina:  拍卖之前首先要他们讲故事
Katrina: Before the auction, they have to tell a story.
Katrina:  才能获得那个币
Katrina: That's how they can earn the coins.
Jake: 对对对就是这个时间
Jake: Yes, yes, exactly.
Jake: 可能就得放一个半小时了
Jake: That might take an hour and a half.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 就就你们昨天的那个活动
Jake: Like your event from yesterday.
Jake: 也也
Jake: Also...
Shure: 也不用讲那么长
Shure: It doesn't have to be that long.
Shure:  就讲一个小故事
Shure: Just tell a short story.
Shure:  一个每个人5分钟那种大概
Shure: Like 5 minutes per person.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: That works.
Shure:  或者时间成本控制不好的话
Shure: Or if we can't control the time well,
Shure:  就以其他形式获得币
Shure: we can earn the coins in other ways.
Shure:  但是这个活动的核心是那个拍卖过程
Shure: But the core of this event is the auction process.
Shure:  但是这个货币怎么获得
Shure: As for how to earn the coins,
Shure:  可以再进一步商榷
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: 拍卖过程这个是要保留的
Shure: We should keep the auction process.
Shure:  大概像9个人的话每个人5分钟
Shure: For about 9 people, each person gets 5 minutes.
Shure:  5945一个小时吧
Shure: 5945 for an hour, right?
Shure:  就按一个小时算的
Shure: Let's just count it as an hour.
Lucia: 我给大家发一些币
Lucia: I'll give everyone some coins.
Lucia: 然后通过摇骰子让大家玩一会
Lucia: Then we can play a bit by rolling dice.
Lucia: 呵呵呵
Lucia: Hehehe.
Katrina: 这这像游戏
Katrina: This feels like a game.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:呵整点游戏可以
Jake: Haha, a bit of game is fine.
Shure:  我们门门口再来一个
Shure: We'll have another one at our door.
默认文本
Default Text
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 没有没有开个玩笑
Lucia: No, no, just kidding.
Katrina:  没关系很快乐
Katrina: It's okay, it's fun.
Katrina:  确实啊
Katrina: Really.
Katrina:  这个听起来有点
Katrina: This sounds a bit...
Lucia: 哈哈哈一会发鸡蛋一会摇色子
Lucia: Hahaha, giving out eggs and rolling dice.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈据点是吧
Jake: Hahaha, it's like a hideout, right?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 一锅端了
Shure: Wiped out in one go.
Shure:  小心这
Shure: Be careful.
Tasha: 进来玩玩嘛
Tasha: Come in and play.
Tasha: 进来就可以获得10个币
Tasha: Come in and you can get 10 coins.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Katrina:  但是一一进来就让
Katrina: But once they come in...
Katrina:  就是刚开始肯定要获得货币
Katrina: At first, they definitely need to get currency.
Katrina:  但是你获得货币
Katrina: But to get the currency...
Katrina:  是要他们通过讲故事的方式
Katrina: They have to tell stories.
Katrina:  但是他们一进来可能还没那么熟
Katrina: But they might not be familiar when they first come in.
Katrina:  就要让他们在众人面前讲故事干什么
Katrina: So making them tell stories in front of everyone...
Tasha:  那就自我介绍
Tasha: Then just do self-introductions.
Katrina:  会冷场
Katrina: It might be awkward.
Tasha: 可以获得一个币啊
Tasha.: They can get a coin for that.
Lucia: 啊自我介绍可以获得
Lucia: Ah, self-introduction can get a coin.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes
Katrina: 啊自我介绍可以获得
Katrina: Ah, introducing yourself can get you...
Jake:自我介绍获得或者
Jake: Introduce yourself to get something or...
Alice: 第一个给5个
Alice: The first one gets 5
Alice: 第二个给仨
Alice: The second one gets 3
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Katrina:  养成机制
Katrina: Like a nurturing mechanism
Jake: 或者我们其实在这个屋子里面
Jake: Or we could actually hide something in this room
Jake: 可以藏点东西
Jake: We can hide stuff
Jake: 然后
Jake: And then...
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia: 像复活节的那种寻彩蛋游戏一样
Lucia: Like an Easter egg hunt game
Jake: 藏点币
Jake: Hide some coins
Shure:  藏币
Shure: Hide coins
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Shure: 也行
Shure: That works
Katrina:  就是刚开始自我介绍获得币
Katrina:  然后玩玩点小游戏赢赢了的币
Katrina: Then play some mini-games to win coins
Shure:  对就比如说
Shure: Yeah, like...
Katrina: 说一些问答什么的
Katrina: Do some Q&A or something
Shure:  野生动物拼图那个
Shure: Like the wildlife puzzle
Lucia:  哎问答的话反正是世界地球日
Lucia: Yeah, since it's Earth Day
Lucia: 对可以
Lucia: That's good
Katrina:  知识问
Katrina: Knowledge Q&A
Lucia: 对答知识问答
Lucia: Right, knowledge Q&A
Shure:  知识问答得币
Shure: Knowledge Q&A to get coins
Shure:  对对对对对
Shure: Yes, yes, yes
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay
Tasha: 世界地球日
Tasha: Earth Day
Shure:  我想怎
Shure: I was thinking...
Katrina: 先要把那个
Lucia: 二十几来着
Lucia: The 20-something
Lucia: 22
Lucia: 22nd
Katrina: 钱给让他们得到
Katrina: Let them get the money
Jake:21来着
Jake: It's the 21st
Katrina:  然后再开始推销
Katrina: And then start promoting
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Katrina: 推销我们的产品
Katrina: Promote our products